Years.
»: Good morning.  I am
Carla at Library of Congress and
I want to welcome you to this
very special story time at the
library.  I love  reading, don't
you??  It is so much fun to let
our imaginations run wild.
We are excited and have teamed
up with Ms.  Ms. Dolly Parton's
Imagination Library to introduce
you to some wonderful authors
who will share their stories
with us.  This partnership works
through her imagination Library
and it is awe-inspiring.
She and her team have given away
over 100 million books to help
encourage
young readers to read across the
world.
Here at the Library of Congress
we share that passion for
developing young readers and we
know that the best way to
encourage people like you to
read is to make reading fun so
that is what we will do.
I hope you enjoy today's story
time.  Even more, I hope you
keep reading at home and having
fun.
Today we will warm up by singing
some
songs, touching your toes, and
then get comfortable and get
ready to here stories.  Now
let's get started!
»: Good morning!
Good morning and welcome to the
library of congress' fifth
imagination
the story time coming to you
from the beautiful pavilion and
today we have a special guest.
My name is Caroline and I come
from the young reader's center
and today we
are welcoming Melissa from the
music division who is going to
read and play her flute.
Melissa Wertheimer, I should say
her last name.
So we are going to start
with our
good morning song, our hello,
friends.
We are going to sing and sign to
the tune of good night ladies.
So the sign for hello is the
salute, just a little salute and
the sign for friends is you take
your two index fingers and you
hug them one way and then the
other way, and the some for
time is do you tap your
imaginary watch and the sign for
to say is you touch your mouth.
Okay?  So hello, friends.
Hello, friends three times.
It is time to say hello.
Hello, friend, hello, friend,
hello, friend, it's time to say
hello.
Good job.
(Applause)
All right so since we are going
to be reading about trains I
thought we should
start off with a little song
that everybody knows -- down by
the station, down by the station
early in the morning, see the
little puffer bellies all in a
row.
See the little engine driver
pull
the little lever, puff, puff,
toot, toot, here we go.
What is a puffer belly?  The
designers called it puffing
Billy
because all of the steam it
created.
So here we go -- down by the
station, early in the morning
See the little puffer bellies
all in a row
See the engine driver pull the
little lever
Puff, puff, toot, toot, off we
go
Down by the station, early in
the morning, see the little
puffer bellies all in a row
See the engine driver
pulled a little lever,
Puff, puff, toot, toot, off we
go!
(Applause)
So now we are going to do a
little
action rhyme and we are going to
make our arms into the wheels
that go chugging down the
tracks.  Can you get your arms
bent?  And then we are going to
move them in a circle.
Okay.
This is choo-choo train.
Here is a little choo-choo
train
puffing down the tracks, now now
it is, leaned forward, and now
it is going back.  Leaned back.
Now the bell is ringing, ding,
ding, now the whistle blows,
toot, toot.
What a lot of noise it makes
(Cover your  ears) Everywhere it
goes.
One more time.
Here is a little choo-choo train
coming down the tracks.
Now it is going forward, and now
it is going back.
Now the bell is ringing, ding,
ding
Now the whistle blows, toot,
toot
What a lot of noise it makes
everywhere it goes!
(Applause)
Good job!
So miss Melissa is going to read
the
classic 19 book by Waddy Piper
and
illustrated by Gerald and Anne
Houseman called what do you
think -- the little engine that
could.
Our theme today is called
persistence or perseverance.
What does that mean?
It means sticking with something
no
matter how hard it gets and not
giving us -- okay?  The little
engine that could.
»: Good morning, everybody.
I have a special job for
everybody out here.
Your job is when ever hear the
sound, toot, toot, do you hear
that  sound?  Your job is to
make the train go.
We have to do our action from
our action rhyme.  And we try
that one more time?  This is the
sound and you have to make the
train go.   Toot, toot.
So this is the little
engine that could.
Toot, toot
The little train rumbled over
the tracks.  She was a happy
little train because
she had such a jolly load to
carry
Her cars were filled full of
good things for boys and girls
There were toy animals, giraffes
with long necks.
There were teddy bears with
almost
no necks at all and even a baby
elephant.
Everybody be an elephant.
We have a baby elephant on the
train.
And then there were dolls, dolls
with blue eyes and yellow curls.
Dolls with brown eyes and brown
bobbed heads and the funniest
toy clown you ever saw
And there were cars full of toy
engines and airplanes, tops,
Jack
Nieves, picture puzzles, books,
and
every kind of thing a boy or
girl could want.
But that was not all -- some of
the cars were filled with all
sorts of good
things for boys and girls to eat
Big gold oranges and red-cheek
apples, bottles of creamy milk
for their breakfast, fresh
spinach for their
dinners, and lollipops for after
dinner treats
The little train was carrying
all of these wonderful things to
the good little boys and girls
on the other side of the
mountain.
She puffed along merrily --
toot, toot
And then all of a sudden she
stopped with a jerk.
She simply could not go another
inch.
She tried and she tried toot,
toot,
but her wheels would not turn
What were all of those good
little boys and girls on the
other side of the mountain going
to do with the wonderful
toys to play with and the good
food to eat?
Here comes a shiny new engine --
toot, toot toot --
said the funny little clown that
jumped out of the train.  Let us
ask him to help us.
So all of the dolls and
toys cried
out together, "Please, shiny new
engine, won't you please pull
our train over the mountain?
Our engine has broken down and
the boys and girls on the other
side won't have any toys to play
with or good food
to eat unless you help us!
But the shiny new engine
snorted.
"I pull you?  I am a passenger
engine.
I have just carried a fine, big
train over the mountain with
more cars then you ever dreamed
of!
My train has sleeping cars with
comfortable births, a dining car
where waiters brings whatever
hungry people
want to eat and parlor cars in
which people sit and big soft
tears and looked
out of place  windows.
I pulled the likes of you?
Indeed not!
"  And off he seemed to the
Roundhouse
where engines live when they are
not
busy
Toot, toot
House sad the little train and
toys all felt.
Then the little clown called
out, "The passenger engine is
not the only one in the world.
Here is another engine coming, a
great big, strong one.  Let us
ask him to help us!
"
Toot, toot
The little toy clown waved his
flag and
the big strong engine came to a
stop.
"Please, oh, please big engine,
cried all the dolls and toys
together, won't you please pull
our train over the mountain?
Are engine has broken down and
the good little boys and girls
on the other
side won't have any toys to play
with or good food to eat unless
you help us.
"  But the big strong engine
bellowed, "I am a freight train.
I had just pulled a big train
loaded with big machines over
the mountains.  These machines
print books and
newspapers for grown-ups to
read.
I am a very important engine
indeed.
I won't pull the likes of you."
And the freight train
puffed off
indignantly to the Roundhouse
Toot, toot
.
Toot, toot.
Toot, toot
The little trains and all of the
dolls was very, very sad.
And now that we are all sad and
we feel defeated, let's take a
little break
for a happy song it is called
the railroad waltz and it is a
dance.  And railroads are
special because we count to
three.  In everybody count to
three?  123
123 all right.
If you would like to dance, here
is a railroad waltz.  We will
get happy a little bit because
that way we will not be so sad
(Flute playing)
(Applause)
»: Beautiful.  Does everybody
feel a little happier?  I hope
so.
So now we get back to our story
where the little train and all
of the dolls
were very sad.   "Cheer up,
cried the little toy clown, this
right engine is not the only one
in the world.  Here comes
another."
Toot, toot.
Toot, toot
He looked very old and tired,
but our train is so little.
So perhaps he can help us.
So the little toy clown waved
his flag
and the rusty old engine stopped
.   "Please, kind engine, cried
all of
the dolls and toys together,
won't you please pull our train
over the mountain?
Our engine has broken down and
the boys and girls on the other
side won't
have any toys to play with or
good food to eat unless you help
us.
"  But the rusty old engine
side, "I am
so tired, I must rest my weary
wheels.  I cannot pull even so
little A-Train
as yours over the mountain.  I
cannot.  I cannot.  I cannot.
"
And off he rumbled to the
Roundhouse,
chugging.
Toot, toot.
Toot, toot
I cannot.  I cannot.  I cannot.
Then indeed the little train was
very
sad and the dolls and toys were
ready to cry.
But the little clown called out,
"Here's another engine coming, a
little
blue engine, a very little one
but maybe she will help us.
"
Toot, toot.
Toot, toot
The very little engine came
chug, chug, chugging merrily
along when she
saw the toy clown's flag, she
stopped quickly.
"What is the matter, my friends,
she asked kindly.
"   "A little blue engine, cried
the dolls and toys, will you
pull us over the mountain?  Our
engine has broken down and the
good boys and girls on the other
side won't have any toys to play
with or good
food to eat unless you help us.
Please, please help us, little
blue engine.
"   "I am not very big, said the
little blue engine.
They use me only for certain
trains in the yard.  I have
never been over the mountain.
"   "But we must get over the
mountain before the children
awake, said all of the dolls and
toys."  And the very little
engine looked up
and she saw the tears in the
dolls' eyes and she thought of
the good little boys and girls
on the other side of the
mountain who would not have any
toys or good food unless she
helped.
Then she said, ""I Think I Can….
I Think I Can….I Think I Can and
she hitched herself to the
little train.
She chugged and she pulled and
pulled
and tugged, and slowly, slowly
they started off.
(Chugging, chugging)
The toy clown jumped aboard
and all of the dolls and toy
animals begin to
smile and cheer (Chugging,
chugging)
Toot, toot
Ding, ding when the little
blue engine, ""I Think I Can….I
Think I Can….I Think I Can I
Think I Can….I Think I Can….I
Think I Can I Think I Can….I
Think I Can….I Think I Can.
"  Up, up, up, faster, and
faster and faster the little
engine climbed until
at last, they reached the top of
the mountain.
Down in the valley lay the city.
"  Hooray!
" Hooray!, cried the funny
little clown and all the dolls
and toys.  The good little boys
and girls in the
city will be happy because you
helped
us, kind little blue engine.
And the little blue engine
smiled and seemed to say as she
puffed steadily
down the mountain -- (Chugging,
chugging) chugging).
Toot, toot.
Toot, toot
(Chugging, chugging).
Toot, toot.
Toot, toot
I thought I could, I
thought I
could, I thought I could, I
thought I could.  The end.
(Applause)
How fabulous!
»: Thank you Ms. Melissa.
Okay.
So let's do an old classic, "I
have been working on the
railroad.
"  We have been working on the
railroad, right?
So she is going to give us our
key (Flute playing)
I had been working on the
railroad, all the live day
I have been working on the
railroad, just to pass the time
away
Can you hear the whistle
blowing,
rise up so early in the morn.
Can't you hear the captain
shouting, Dinah blow your horn.
Dinah, won't you blow, Dinah,
won't
you blow, oh, Dinah, won't you
blow your horn?
Dinah, won't you blow, Dinah,
won't you blow, oh, Dinah, won't
you blow your horn
Someone is in the kitchen with
Dinah
Someone is in the kitchen I know
Is someone is in the kitchen
with
Dinah, Stremming on the old
banjo
Fee-fi-fiddly-eye-oh
Strumming on the old banjo.
(Applause)
»: Wonderful!  Great
singing!
All right, so we have come to
the and of our livestream.
Let's sing our goodbye song,
which is the opposite of the
hello, song.
So we are going to wave goodbye,
friends, waved goodbye to
friends
It is time to say goodbye
Goodbye, friends
Goodbye friends, it is time to
say goodbye.
See you next month.
(Applause)
All right!  So stick around --
do you need to go
back --
(Story time is over.  Thank you
for joining us)
CAPTIONER:
10:53 AM (EST)